so talk to me about moving to el
salvador and getting the uh citizenship
one why are you moving why are you
getting the citizenship but also two how
does it actually work from a
kind of operational standpoint right so
um the volcano bonds that uh there's a
big story um
what was an idea that was floated is
that similar to other countries that
offer citizenship economic citizenship
like um
in in the um
bermuda and other countries bermuda
think kids same kids portugal they all
do it yep they have there's a different
programs out there so the idea was
floated hey you know you put a hundred
thousand into these volcano bonds and
you're on the fast track to citizenship
or permanent residency so i tweeted that
you know i'm we're very interested in
this we would love to become
salvadorian citizens and
within a half hour we were getting
tweets back and feedback
back from the president and other people
in the government saying you know we'll
make you citizens um
asap you know by the end of this year uh
we'll get you we'll get you your
citizenship we we want entrepreneurs we
think you guys would be great
um kind of um
leading the pack in a whole wave of
bitcoin immigrants who are looking for
bitcoin city looking for a bitcoin
country um so i
i think for me this is the biggest thing
since the genesis block you know for me
so i've been in this for 10 years
uh this is the most exciting thing i've
i've seen really in many many years and
i've always tried to be at the front of
the
the front of the you know the tip of the
spear or you know the really the the
edge of what's happening and i think
this is it so uh that's what that's put
all together and packing our bags and
going yeah would you guys uh become uh
salvadorian citizens i would i'm curious
like what the uh what the response was
from or the vibe from like citizens down
there are they do they understand
exactly what's going on are they super
excited about it are they uh looking to
learn more just kind of your guys
thoughts on that
well my pitch to everybody is um
essentially here's unconfiscatable money
it's censorship proof money right and
everybody wants to have savings everyone
wants to have some store of wealth
everybody wants to build a nest egg
everyone wants to have a future
and the problem in these various
countries is that they've been dealing
with inflation and hyperinflation and
corruption
and so when you say look here's
money that you only you control and it's
the hardest money ever that just
immediately gets people's attention and
it's a real
it's a real
need there's a need for it whereas in
the u.s a lot of people because this is
a much different situation it's more
seen as a tech project or it's a it's
something a fad or something there's no
a lot of people here don't see it as a
as a real burning need
but except for maybe the uh you know i
was very early on
talking to the black community in
america you know if you look at isaiah
jackson's book bitcoin in black america
he mentions me in like the second page
and saying he heard about it with kaiser
report uh max kaiser a notable white man
was uh you know um proselytizing bitcoin
and the black community in america is uh
the highest concentration of bitcoin
adoption in america for the simple
reason that's unconfiscatable wealth you
know this is a community that's had its
wealth confiscated over and over and
over again for you know 300 years right
so you say here's unconfiscatable wealth
those are the the two magic words and
it's like
all right i'm in
uh and so that's true all over the world
all over the world especially with the
us dollar gemini all over the world
inflation is now huge all over the world
and uh as an inflation protection as
many have explained it so brilliantly uh
bitcoin is par excellence really it's
nothing better